School Professor Francisco Canyon was 15
years old when the eruption of the
Nevada de Ruiz volcano hit the town of
Murillo in 1985.
the memories of fleeing with his father
as burning rocks hurled through the
night and the Roar of the landslide
still haunt him to this day
even if I was very young I had the
impression that the Earth could cave in
or that something was arriving from the
sky
now that the volcano might be erupting
again he packed a backpack with a radio
a light documents and medicines to be
ready to run again
people living in the shadows of the
Nevada de Ruiz have been on high alert
for two weeks authorities say the
volcano might be days or weeks away from
another major eruption
and no one knows where it will hit the
hardest
Nelly who lived in a rural area close to
the volcano still gets emotional
remembering how she and her three
children miraculously survived
a
cake for days I wouldn't go to bed
thinking it would come back and I
wouldn't be able to open my eyes again I
would think about my kids it's very hard
to remember because I suffered so much
it stays with you
re-emerged relatively unskated another
town armero was completely wiped away
killing 25
000 people
a gigantic Landslide traveled for more
than 50 kilometers through the night
bearing our mirror in a matter of
minutes and leaving its residence
without a chance to survive
despite the past tragedy authorities are
struggling to convince many farmers in
high risk areas to evacuate and soldiers
have been deployed to stop vehicles from
heading to the volcano
geologists say they are worried by the
fact that the activity inside the
volcano is the closest it has been to
the one that preceded in 1985 eruption
even if there are differences
in 1985 the volcano was closed gases
didn't have a way out today the system
is more open yet the seismic activity is
similar especially in the southwest of
the volcano a dangerous Omen from a
volcano that has already shown to be
capable of explosive eruptions and
landslides to swallow everything in
their path Alessandro al-jazeer armero